No, don't go on a second date with him.
He sounds like a jerk.
He also dated Kimmy's ex, so you don't even want to be anywhere near that.
I mean, I'm at work but I'm not...
As anyone who works in a cubicle knows...
...sitting next to someone who yaps all day can make it really hard to focus.
What a jerk!
Okay, seriously.
Okay.
You can skip the noise-cancelling headphones.
They only work on ambient sounds like the hum of a plane engine.
Instead, you can use regular headphones and go to myNoise.net.
There, you can choose from a variety of distraction-busting sounds...
...like ocean waves or bird song.
I like babble noise.
Turn the volume up just enough to camouflage the conversation your colleague is having.
It will sound weird at first but you'll get used to it.
And it's highly effective, so you can at last get back to work.